we have conflicting reports about a
possible major development in the fight
against Isis Russia's military claimed
overnight and airstrike in Syria may
have killed Abu Bakr al-baghdadi the
leader of the terror group
it says the airstrike last month
targeted an isis gathering outside Raqqa
that's a de facto capital but multiple
sources in the Pentagon and the State
Department cannot confirm his death and
the Russian Foreign Ministry is also
unsure about al Baghdadi's fate Holly
Williams is in Istanbul with the latest
on this story Holly good morning good
morning russia's Foreign Minister Sergey
Lavrov admitted today that Russia does
not have a hundred percent confirmation
that it killed Abu Bakr al Baghdadi
Russia is apparently checking whether or
not he was killed by an airstrike
allegedly targeting a meeting of Isis
leaders near Raqqa in Syria in the early
hours of May 28th that's nearly 20 20
days ago now the whereabouts of our
Baghdadi have long been a mystery there
have been many rumors of his death and
he's very rarely been captured on camera
he did appear in 2014 in Mosul Iraq to
proclaim himself the caliph or leader of
his so-called Islamic state we do not
know how much of a role he played in
Isis militarily or strategically or how
much impact his death would have on the
group other than symbolically al
Baghdadi rose to become the leader of
al-qaeda's offshoot in Iraq later
splitting with Al Qaeda's leadership
which has criticized Isis for its
brutality Jeff Holly Williams in
Istanbul thank you